aus meiner Sicht ist es ganz
entscheidend dass wir aus 20151 gelernt
haben und das ist kein Abschied von
Merkel sondern Merkel hat sich von der
Union verabschiedet wir müssen uns
weiterentwickeln und es ist eine
innovative Fortentwicklung bei dem was
droht womöglich wassenflucht aus dem
Balkan was sich gerade im Kosovo
zuspitzt und in Bosnien dann haben wir
die Herausforderung der Türkei in
berkarabach haben wir Schwierigkeiten
und wir wissen nicht wie das mit der
Ukraine weitergeht Frau Merkel ist
konservativer als die Union heute ist
aha aber noch Frau Merkel ist
also wann hat sich Angela Merkel aus der
Union verabschiedet wann genau ist das
sie hat sich letzte Woche aus der Konrad
Aden Stiftung
verabschiedet und ich glaube nicht dass
sie sich aus der Union verabschiedet hat
sie ist ja nach wie vor Mitglied aber
wir haben gesehen dass das was ihre
Politik war mit dem 22 Februar 24
Februar letzten Jahres vorbei war